Launchpad 39a it's the place where we
sent humans to the moon but now this
Launchpad is on the market and SpaceX
has won the lease do you want to get on
dragon I think I probably will take a
trip though of it at some point Kennedy
Space Center is emblematic of a change
in how Americans explore space my
message to the team when I got here was
the shuttle program is going to end and
we have to start preparing for the
future Brevard County Florida depended
on NASA for its economic survival at the
height of the shuttle program in the
early 90s nineteen thousand people
worked at Kennedy Space Center when
Atlantis took its last flight in 2011
over 7,000 employees were suddenly out
of a job today 78 hundred people work at
the once bustling campus why are these
commercial companies wanting to come
here and wanting to utilize this
building it's cost-effective yeah I mean
here's a building here's the space
available you don't have to build
anything you just have to configure it
for your rocket it has more capacity
than we need so rather than just let it
sit dormant why not enable commercial
space operations the space shuttle
program occupied 390 facilities on
Kennedy's campus today seven of those
buildings are being handed over to
private enterprise one new tenant has
already started moving in Boeing has
signed leases for several spaces on
Kennedy's
campus one is Launchpad 41 the other is
NASA's opf 3 an abandoned factory where
Boeing hopes to employ more than 300
people
this is orbiter processing facility
number 3 or used to be Chris Ferguson
piloted America's last shuttle and his
new mission is to get bonus commercial
space program off the ground I think in
a couple years when you come in here
it's it's not gonna be so cavernous and
empty I think you're gonna hear the
clanking of work being done
neither NASA nor Boeing would talk
numbers yet a user agreement reveals
that the fair market value for opf 3 is
about 13 and a half million dollars but
the real cost for NASA is in the
maintenance launch pad 39a currently
cost NASA about one hundred thousand
dollars a month in upkeep some people
say that NASA's glory days are behind
them as well couldn't be further from
the truth our glory days are in front of
us we are charging ahead into the future
we have been going back and forth to low
Earth orbit for 50 years now we know how
to do that it is time to transition to
the commercial space industry